speaking of absolute spoiled breath fake
news Washington Post a few other papers
but Washington Post ran this article the
headline an Airbnb host reportedly
leaves guests stranded because of her
race did this person who was renting out
of Airbnb appeared to be a bigot yeah
racist maybe did this person not rent
out to this girl because she was a
racist absolutely not that's not what
occurred here so let's let's let's pull
first the screenshots it says go ahead
this is the person who would be renting
out to the other person to host I
wouldn't rent to you if you were the
last person on earth one word says it
all
Asian at first glance that seems pretty
bad this is fake news and we will
describe people term is thrown around a
lot fake news that it's lost all meaning
I think this defines it let's watch the
clip first she said this is why we have
Trump and she said like we can't have
foreigners telling us what to do she
said that's me I'm an American citizen
this is my home I was I've been here
since I was three years old America is
my home I consider myself an American
but this woman discriminates against me
for being Asian okay don't laugh yet so
let's do we have a Facebook page yeah
this is a Facebook page of this girl who
was making the accusation for those who
haven't read says she was loving like
she wants to abolish prisons and
capitalism okay and she is studying race
relations in Los Angeles which is
actually kind of uncommon for an issue
we're talking about social justice
warriors so abolish prison and
capitalism's and she's studying race
relations why does all of this matter
okay let me tell you why you can only
have so many clock boys UVA 's mattress
girls the lesbian who claimed that she
had an anti homophobic slur written on
her receipt Duke Lacrosse group swastika
swastika you can only have so many of
these stories when you do a little
digging and find out that this person is
an activist who just so happens to walk
face-first into the perfect kind of
story that they've been shared
their Facebook Timeline for years right
and if you watch that video they have
b-roll they have light setup they're
putting chains on their tires like any
boy with race and passion curve I can
the Washington Post said when they were
minutes away from the cabin saw the hope
I'm saying that correctly sent a message
to the host through Airbnb app to let
her know that they were closed and how
they might pay for adding the two
friends to the reservation here's the
thing the story does not include the
next screenshot that we're about to show
you and the context is not provided so
we actually cannot corroborate this
girl's argument this is four months ago
by the way
yeah it just became a mystery committee
because who knows who knows millions of
plays happened over a month ago and now
a million displays uploaded to a channel
by someone who apparently worked for
KTLA but the story didn't go to hkey TLA
again if you watch the video clip it was
supposed to directly to youtube but it
was made from Windows Movie Maker they
had time to edit in screenshots do you
letting this is a setup
yeah I do now she claims that she was
willing to pay more okay
she's provided every other screenshot
why didn't you provide those screenshots
because here is where the screenshots
start the host says this if you think
four people and two dogs are getting a
room for $50 a night on Big Bear
Mountain during the busiest weekend of
the year you are insanely high funny not
as a business of a person mind you but
that's funny
and then the host also identified her as
a con artist before the Asian bit and
then canceled so did this person not
host this girl because she was Asian
no she was clearly willing to or this
person maybe was I don't know who the
guy or a woman who was a host I'm not
sure I'm not entirely sure the host was
willing to rent this place out had a
contractual agreement anyone who works
at Airbnb this is the rape okay and was
why it was already done the deal was
done until this asian girl decided to
renegotiate five minutes out and so the
person got mad kind of like you get into
an argument with your wife and you say
things afterward that you don't really
mean is because you're angry but that's
not really the root cause of the
argument you know I eyes so much someone
forgot to unload the dishwasher
therefore this is why your mother killed
herself I'm just drawing an example of
course but the point is if you can have
an argument here it was about the
dishwasher well that could be the case
here this person was mad because they
had rented out they
blocked out their place which they can
no longer rent to somebody else this is
often how people make their living or
it's a huge chunk of their living with
the sharing economy and then all of a
sudden five minutes away this person's
going to renegotiate they feel screws in
the deal they get natural they say
something racist the thing that they
said that was racist does not erase all
the horrible behavior before that and
you know who gets the shortest of the
stick on this one all Asians who are not
this girl perpetuating the horrible
original Asian stereotype she agreed to
a deal and then by the way two more
people and two puppies that's the
negative Asian stereotype that they
constantly try to haggle they currently
try to change the deal another law this
is how dare you sharing it well I just
want a second I wonder where could I
have possibly gotten this stereotype if
there's someplace that we could have
heard it before because Indian cannot
live without a bargain and Chinese
people cannot give you a bargain their
objective is to get every penny from you
and I just to keep every penny oh that's
right
Asians is it fake I don't know does it
look like a setup
absolutely the difficulty a poorly
absolutely was the headline fake that
this person refused to enter because she
was Asian 100% what occurred here was an
entitled abolished prisoners abolished
capitals and little socialists who
studies race relations at USC or UCLA I
can't remember right now decides that
she's going to walk face-first into a
wonderful social justice story by
agreeing having a verbal and written
contractual agreement and then switching
the deal when the person gets mad enough
to see the racist thing that she was
likely hoping for her to say take some
screenshots happen to have a camera crew
and call Washington Post and Los Angeles
Times
it's a bad date raisins on this we have
a flair for the dramatic you know how
adults react if someone says something
horrible if this is going races miss
having sex is like I would never rent
you ever because you're Asian you're a
dick and you move on okay but this girl
just behaved so morally tried to change
the deal right when they're five minutes
from from the Airbnb could you imagine
if you try to pull this crap at any
other hotel you know what usually
happens okay your room is going to come
to one twenty two fifty okay um look I
need a bigger room for two more people
in two dogs at the same price know what
if I pay more though okay okay if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if not
there's a strong chance that you're an
Armenian genocide denier when coin then
you know what I'm talking about but I
don't over there if isn't the channel
for you I'm sure you'll find something
there that you deem very insightful and
informative also I requested you come
back here afterward and immediately
leave a negative comment because we read
those and those affect our lives
directly we care about them because we
care about you